♪ ♪
>> Greg: HERE'S A FUN FACT
ABOUT NYC.
MURDER IS UP 55% THIS YEAR.
SORRY.
THAT'S NOT A FUN FACT.
THAT'S A TERRIFYING FACT
ESPECIALLY IF YOU LIVE IN
NEW YORK OR ARE A TOURIST.
FROM THE START OF 2019 THERE'S
BEEN 48 KILLINGS, ALMOST ONE PER
DAY.
LAST YEAR THIS TIME THERE WERE
31.
THANKFULLY, MARY BILL
DE BLASIO, A.K.A. CAPTAIN
LERCH, IS HERE, ANNOUNCING ALL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WILL BE GOING
MEATLESS ON MONDAYS.
I BET THIS IS IMPORTANT ON SO
MANY LEVELS.
>> THIS IS IMPORTANT ON SO MANY
LEVELS.
I'VE GOT TO SAY IF YOU ARE
THINKING ABOUT OUR KIDS
INDIVIDUALLY, WE WANT THEM TO BE
AS HEALTHY AS THEY CAN BE AND WE
WANT THEM TO LEARN AS WELL AS
THEY CAN LEARN.
MEATLESS MONDAYS WILL HELP.
IT WILL CREATE MORE BALANCE IN
THEIR LIVES.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A CLIMATE,
THE EXISTENTIAL THREAT OF GLOBAL
WARMING.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE DO THAT'S
ANOTHER CONTRIBUTION TO
ADDRESSING GLOBAL WARMING,
STRIKING MORE OF A BALANCE IN
OUR WHOLE SOCIETY.
>> Greg: CUTTING BACK ON MEAT
WILL HELP SAVE THE PLANET.
SO WOULD ELIMINATING THE
CROSS-COUNTRY TOUR HE PLANS TO
TAKE.
WHEN THINGS AREN'T GOING WELL AT
HOME, BEST TO RUN AWAY.
BETWEEN CRIME AND SCANDALS, I
WOULD LEAVE TOO.
THE MAYOR SHOVELED NEARLY
900 MILLION BUCKS INTO HIS
WIFE'S MENTAL HEALTH INITIATIVE.
THAT'S NUTS.
WE HAVE STILL YET TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE THE MONEY WENT.
YOU TAKE THE SUBWAY, YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT MENTAL HEALTH AND
THAT'S CRIMINAL.
THE CITY THAT WE LOVE NEEDS HELP
BUT IT'S RUN BY LEFT-WING
DEMOCRAT SO THAT MENTALLY ILL
ARE LEFT TO LANGUISH BECAUSE THE
LEFT HAS MADE IT ACCEPTABLE TO
LANGUISH.
MEANWHILE CRIME CREEPS BACK UP
WHILE AMAZON AND IT'S 25    25,0
JOBS FLEE.
LERCH IS ONLY MAYOR OF NEW YORK.
THE BAD NEWS IS THAT HE'S HEADED
YOUR WAY BEARING TOFU.
I'M GOING TO GO TO THE
VEGETARIAN FIRST.
JESSE.
>> Jesse: [LAUGHS]
>> Greg: I THOUGHT CAFETERIAS
WERE ALWAYS MEATLESS BECAUSE
THAT WASN'T MEAT.
>> Jesse: MYSTERY MEAT.
>> Greg: WEIRD STUFF.
I DON'T THINK ANIMALS EXIST TO
CREATE THAT.
>> Dana: COME ON.
THEY HAVE GOOD FOOD AT SCHOOLS.
>> Greg: SOMEBODY IS SPONSORED
BY BIG MEAT.
>> Jesse: BIG CATTLE.
THE WYOMING LADY.
AND WANTING TO BE THE MAYOR, NOT
THE LUNCH LADY.
THE CITY IS A MESS.
YOU CAN'T DRIVE ANYWHERE.
LOSS 25,000 JOBS WITH AMAZON.
HE CAN'T HANDLE A SNOWSTORM.
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING FOR LOWER
TAXES.
STAY OUT OF OUR FOOD CHOICES,
MR. MAYOR.
THIS IS A PUBLICITY STAND.
IF KIDS HAVE PASTA ON MONDAY,
IT'S NOT GOING TO REDUCE THE
EARTH TEMPERATURE.
YOU POINTED OUT --
>> Greg: OR THEIR BODY WEIGHT.
>> Jesse: IF HE CUTS BACK ON
HIS PRIVATE JET FLIGHTS THAT
WOULD REDUCE EMISSIONS.
THE ONLY THING HE'S WORRIED
ABOUT HIS COWS GETTING MURDERED,
NOT PEOPLE GETTING MURDERED.
THE WHOLE THING IS A JOKE.
KIDS NEED PROTEIN.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE CEREAL
FOR BREAKFAST AND LENTILS FOR
LUNCH.
AND THE STUDENT ATHLETES ARE
SUPPOSED TO GO OUT AND PERFORM,
GO TO THE WEIGHT ROOM, HIT THE
COURT?
THESE KIDS ARE GOING TO PASS
OUT.
EVEN THE SPEECH TEAM IS GOING TO
PASS OUT.
>> Dana: [LAUGHS]
>> Greg: THEY WILL BE
SPEECHLESS.
MEATLESS AND SPEECHLESS.
ALL RIGHT, DAGEN, YOU ARE THE
ACTUAL VEGAN HERE.
I WILL SAY YOU COULD GET FAT AS
A VEGETARIAN BECAUSE ITS
CARBOHYDRATES, NOT PROTEIN.
I KNOW HE'S MAKING IT AN
ENVIRONMENTAL CLAIM.
>> Dagen: TATER TOTS AND
FRENCH FRIES ARE WHAT THEY GOING
TO GET.
IF YOU WOULD NEVER DO THIS BUT
MAKE YOUR MEATLESS FRIDAYS AND
THEN THAT WOULD BE -- HELP
CATHOLICS WHO DON'T EAT ANY MEAT
ON FRIDAYS.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE STEAMING SACK OF COOKED
CABBAGE WOULD NEVER, EVER DO
THAT BECAUSE AGAIN IT WOULD BE
RELIGIOUS IN SOME WAY, SHAPE, OR
FORM.
HE'S WORRIED ABOUT SAVING MOTHER
EARTH, MAKE THE SIBLINGS RUN.
LET PEOPLE AVOID GETTING IN
THEIR CARS AND GET IN THE
SUBWAYS AND NOT GET THEIR FACES
CAUGHT OR PUSHED AND THROWN IN
FRONT OF A MOVING TRAIN.
IT SHOULDN'T TAKE TWO AND A HALF
HOURS TO GET 60 MILES FROM
CONNECTICUT INTO NEW YORK CITY.
HE'S GOT HIS PRIORITIES
MISPLACED.
HE'S WORRYING ABOUT PEOPLE
HAVING HAMBURGER.
>> Greg: I WANT MY TAX MONEY
TO GO TO MENTAL HEALTH.
I CAN THINK OF ANYTHING MORE
IMPORTANT.
>> Dana: IF IT ACTUALLY WENT
THERE.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT BUGS ME.
I TRIED TO LOOK AND FIND OUT
WHERE THIS MONEY WENT.
IT MEANS IT'S ALMOST A DOUBLE
CRIME.
>> Dana: THE ANNOUNCEMENT
ABOUT THE 900 MILLION INTO THE
MENTAL HEALTH WAS ON THE SAME
WEEK THAT THEY ANNOUNCED THAT
THE MAYOR HAD $773 MILLION
FORWARD NO PROJECT FOR SCHOOLS,
ALSO DEEMED A FAILURE.
THAT'S MONEY DOWN THE DRAIN.
LENTILS IS PROTEIN.
BUT KIDS NEED PROTEIN.
>> Jesse: IS NOT GOING TO FILL
YOU UP.
>> Juan: YES.
>> Jesse: LET'S DO SOME
VARSITY FOOTBALL PLAYERS EATING
LENTIL SOUP FOR LUNCH.
>> Juan: THERE ARE A BUNCH OF
NFL AND NBA PLAYERS WHO DON'T
EAT MEAT.
I DON'T THINK --
>> Jesse: THEY DON'T WIN
CHAMPIONSHIPS.
>> Juan: APART FROM THE
BASHING OF BILL de BLASIO
WHICH I THINK IS UNFAIR, CRIME
IN THIS TOWN YOU SHOULD KNOW IS
DOWN 8% THIS YEAR.
MOST OF THESE MURDERS, GANG
RELATED IN ONE SECTION, NORTH
BROOKLYN.
>> Greg: SO THEY DON'T MATTER?
THAT'S KIND OF RACIST.
>> Juan: I LOVE PLAYING ALONG
WHEN "THE FIVE" BASHES PEOPLE.
I GUESS THEY THINK --
>> Greg: THANK GOD YOU DON'T
BASH ANYBODY.
>> Juan: GOING AFTER
DE BLASIO.
>> Dagen: A POT HOLE AS BIG AS
A REFRIGERATOR IN FRONT OF MY
APARTMENT BUILDING.
>> Juan: YOU SHOULD GO TO
DETROIT AND BALTIMORE AND CHECK
OUT SOME OTHER CITIES.
>> Jesse: WE ARE BETTER THAN
DETROIT.
IS THAT YOUR ARGUMENT?
>> Juan: MY ARGUMENT IS THIS
TOWN IS ATTRACTING MORE YOUNG
PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: NOT FROM AMAZON.
>> Dana: EVERYTHING'S GREAT.
>> Juan: THIS TOWN IS A
BOOMTOWN.
MY POINT IS THE HEALTH OF THESE
KIDS, I THINK WHAT de BLASIO
IS SAYING ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
IS RIDICULOUS BUT I THINK WHEN
IT COMES TO STAYING TO KIDS, YOU
ARE BEING PUSHED HAMBURGERS ON
YOU, HOT DOGS.
TAKE A BREAK FROM EATING MEAT.
>> Dagen: HE'S NOT THE
STUDENT'S DADDY.